I was so I sort of as a young
environmentalist I think came of age
the death of environmentalism I'm as an
ideological movement environmentalism
was was breaking down or showing itself
to be to not be working i'm curious
whether you see sort of the capitalist
side of what you do the investing as a
continuation of environmentalism or are
the separate things is one more
effective than the other I think you
have to do it all and iris actually was
up here at Yale when the two gentlemen
who presented the essay of death of
environmentalism first came out and and
they were brilliant and it was
controversial and what they did the
reason why we make investments
environmental investments is we believe
that it is an important component of
solving the problems that the
environmental problems that we are
facing are so large they can't be solved
entirely with traditional grant-making
in philanthropy and so we believe that
making investments in clean energy and
sustainable agriculture and all and and
other things outside of our expertise
are an important mix and complement
traditional grant people that's your
answer did I answer it yeah they do you
think there was a place for that type of
or where's the place went in the cabinet
world where the the investment model is
less effective or more effective than
philanthropy all right right I think
that that you need both ran and basic
philanthropy which is to me traditional
flavors grant-making where foundations
like ours are making a grant to
nonprofits here it is it's a grant it is
an investment we're making an investment
in an organization but we are not
getting a financial return we are only
hoping that there is an impact return a
mission return of what's going on there
are many instances where that's not
enough and and many of the organizations
that we work with in the environmental
world realize probably about ten years
ago that grant making isn't enough an
example is the Nature Conservancy one of
the largest environmental organizations
and a great organization that we support
they you know they have a very large
budget that comes from philanthropy but
to say
the land that they need to save for
biodiversity all around the world is far
greater the dollars needed a far greater
than they're going to get from
fundraising so they need to find other
pools of capital they need to find folks
who will invest as opposed to or in
addition to just donate or they'll find
individuals who own land who will treat
their land responsibly so this new world
that we're living in that today is
called impact investing which is where I
spend a lot of time is really the
intersection of finding out where
there's traditional grant-making where
in between that and where there's purely
for profit investing that has no social
or environmental return where we are is
in the middle and there's a really need
need for all of that to happen